i'm not doing a conservative talk show
i'm doing an american talk show trying
to hold the country together and joining
us now on the show is a guy who
literally wrote the book
on holding the country together he's
probably going to get cancelled for it
this is a very controversial thing to
say but we're thrilled to have him
connecticut senator former connecticut
senator joe lieberman with us on the
show hey man how are you
good jimmy great to be with you thanks
for working to hold the country together
because
unless we stop the division we're not
going to be
the country we've been and want to be so
anyway for sure
well i will thank you and i was thinking
about you because you know i read
somewhere that your parents ran a liquor
store and i got to tell you they could
be making big money if they had that
business now
yeah that's uh that was it i mean my dad
you know came out of high school in the
depression couldn't go to college worked
on on little
bakery trucks and stuff like that
uh worked his way down to stanford
connecticut where he met my mom
had a dance and they got engaged and
two of my
mother's
sisters were married to guys who ran
liquor stores so they said why don't you
go to a liquor store we'll put you in
the business you you've invited a little
story quickly so my father said sure so
they said uh and you can marry marsha uh
when you're when you're bringing in 25
bucks a week
so that was that was quite an incentive
system
and as my dad would tell he worked
pretty hard and that was marrying my
mother pretty soon after they started
the story that's a great one yeah that's
a great no it's a great american story
and i appreciate you sharing it and you
know i'm going to dive in i want to ask
you about your book it's called the
centrist solution how we made government
work and can make it work again so uh
you know i know uh you know of you and
your career and that you've always been
bargaining with the american people in
good faith and it's obviously something
i appreciate so my question for you on
this one
is when it comes to you know making
government work and making it work again
do you feel like on some level in the
age of social media you know it's almost
impossible to compromise because we're
portraying our ideological opposites in
the most extreme terms imaginable that
it doesn't seem relatable to you know to
someone on the left that you'd work with
those white supremacists on the right or
the someone on the right that you'd work
with those commies on the left
yeah absolutely i mean you i think
you've touched on one of the causes um
look at the the the central solution
uh is about whether people in this
country now
are are ready to do what uh americans
have always done when we've had a
problem uh we come to the center and i
don't mean everybody's a moderate i mean
left right
republican whatever you are you come
basically
and sit down at the table the american
table
together and you talked about the
problem respectfully civilly
and and then you try to figure out do we
have common ground you compromise you
don't get everything but you get a lot
done for the country and uh when people
are constantly
uh insulting each other as they are on
social media it's pretty hard to
let's put it this way it's harder
to bring them to the table to sit down
in a trustworthy way with people who
have a different point of view so you're
absolutely right i mean the internet is
a is a wonderful thing it's improved our
lives in so many ways but it's also
been used
for reasons that are harmful to our
society and that's one too much the ease
of attacking
somebody who just happens to have a
different point of view than you do but
is your fellow american yeah everybody
forgets that and if you're just joining
us yeah if you're just joining us joe
lieberman is on the line the new book is
called the centrist solution how we made
government work and can make it work
again and i would agree with you that
nowhere in the world is there a guy
who'd be better off if only he spent
another hour on twitter
that's the first time i've ever heard
that and i'm gonna repeat it i'll
probably give you credit for it like the
first two times i use it
good for you
you know i'm like a public utility you
just you come on you take what you need
for me it's fine i'm here for you
no but you're you're right you know
and uh
it's you know somebody once told me so
my in my religious education a rabbi
said that he once read from another
rabbi that your language is um you can't
get it back once you use it he said it's
like if you took your down pillow
and opened it up and let the feathers
fly out
all over you're just never going to get
them back
that's the way it is when you say
something nasty about
somebody else it's hard to retrieve it
hard to fix it
well here's something i it's very
interesting to me and i wanted to get
your take on this as as you've been on
every side of this in washington
um
when we talk now about what's going on
with the you know the spending bill
that's being negotiated the
reconciliation bill and everything in
between
is there anyone in politics right or
left that's sincerely interested in
cutting spending or is that ship sailed
and it's just modern monetary theory
from here on because i hear even
republicans talk about spending but i
i've got to call them out because when
they get into power they're not exactly
playing a prevent defense you know
yeah no you're right i mean
traditionally
uh uh in this overstates it simplifies
it but democrats have been the big
spenders and uh republicans uh have been
much more concerned about paying for
stuff and
and limiting spending and avoiding the
debt because somebody has to pay it
eventually uh bill clinton was an
exception as a democrat who really
worked hard to balance the budget worked
hard with newt gingrich i mean talk
about a central solution they
balanced budget act of 1997. a lot of
people were involved but they were the
leaders clinton and gingrich and lo and
behold the last three years
of the clinton administration there was
a surplus in the federal budget we
haven't seen it since but there has now
been a change
in the republican party not all of it
and and
i say this respectfully toward president
trump he seemed to be less concerned
about uh government spending
than uh previous republican leaders
were so
and now the republicans are opposed to
this big social service entitlement
spending bill that the democrats are
trying to push through congress so i
appreciate that but uh unfortunately
both parties have allowed the spending
to get out of control you know today
last time i looked which was last week
the national
debt
uh that's the accumulated debt over the
years is approaching
28 trillion dollars i mean just think
about how much our kids and grandkids
and their kids are going to have to pay
in taxes
to pay off that debt it's just it's
irresponsible of us to do that yeah i
think it's i think it's reckless too and
uh you know trump's the one thing i will
say trump's spending didn't surprise me
only because you know when you read that
the guy owns a gold toilet i would
assume he has a problem spending money
you know what i'm saying
oh see there you go a gold toilet
for every american
we went from a chicken in every pot to a
pot made out of 24 karat gold i love it
um
but this was really politically
significant during this campaign in 2016
they asked him how he felt about cutting
social security and medicare and long it
had long been at my time in the senate
that the typical republican position now
we're not going to cut spending on
social security and medicare but we have
to limit the increase so they're going
to run out of money but uh president
trump candidate trump and then president
said no i'm not going to cut spending on
social security and medicare and i think
he had a political intuition that a lot
of working-class americans who now were
who you had been democrats who were fed
up with the democratic party for other
reasons would come to him so long as
they know they knew he was not going to
cut their social security medicare
safety net so that of course that added
to spending as well though it helped to
elect them the first time so definitely
i i think in that regard he had a better
gauge of what the boots on the ground
the voters themselves were experiencing
i he did come off as i think a little
more in touch with the you know the main
street american but the thing i wanted
to ask you about the democratic party is
are you concerned that in this iteration
of joe biden he's i don't know if he's
been hijacked or what the case may be
but they seem to be veering too far to
the left it's almost like they elected
bernie do you feel that way a little bit
well i worry about it i mean i've been
in this battle for a long time within
the democratic party uh clinton uh and i
and others were in something called the
democratic leadership council in the 80s
and 90s that fought to bring the party
back to the center and of course clinton
got elected and he governed from there
but
falling back again to where uh was uh
before that uh and the the the far left
it's not just center left
it which is the traditional democratic
coalition this is a far-left group
the most extreme of which is the
so-called squad and they seem to be
exercising influence
far beyond their numbers and certainly
in the country and i believe in the
party i think most democrats today uh
rank and file are still center and and
slightly left but not far left like
there and and some for reasons i don't
know exactly joe biden who was really
more of a centrist in the 24 years i
served with him in the senate will
always work
to have bipartisan agreements often with
very conservative republicans like strom
thurman and aaron hatch he seems to be
have been pulled over
by those further left democrats finally
he's trying to cut them back some on
this big new entitlement bill
but he's having a hard time doing it and
i think that that's i think he got
elected the margin of victory over
president trump was because a lot of uh
moderates uh thought he was a moderate
it would work across party lines and do
what we talked about at the beginning
unify america but uh it so far it's not
happened yeah it's been a mess if you're
just joining us joe lieberman is on the
line uh connecticut long time
connecticut senator vice presidential
nominee hey let me ask you this as a
vice presidential nominee uh where were
you to have become the vice president of
the united states and get put in charge
of securing our southern border do you
think you could have done as good a job
as kamala harris has done
well it's a hard job but
at different times and there's no
perfect solution just because we have
such a big southern border and so many
people are almost dying to get in here
most of them because they're trying to
make more money than they could make
south of the border or even as we saw a
little while ago in places like haiti
that come in through the mexican border
but
we could yeah i i never this is like um
it's this is not an either or choice i
mean i think you gotta you gotta have
listen i'm pro-immigration my
grandparents were all immigrants to the
country i think immigration has made the
country great but you got to have rules
you can't just
let any everybody in it just doesn't
work that way
and uh so i think we can secure the
border and then make some rules
about uh
who's coming in and and who's not we can
we can do it both if we uh if we want to
it's a real problem i mean it's a plus
to have people coming in to help the
country but
the numbers have really skyrocketed
lately we just got to do something about
it that's all i mean the old adage in
sports is that defense wins
championships but nobody told our new
york jets they've never heard the saying
but
you're good you're very good hey thanks
i'm trying i'm trying over here uh i'll
stick with these drugs i kid i kid uh
the book
i would say working for you i don't know
you know that line came back to me
that's robert de niro in that great
movie he did with billy crystal okay
poor chris was the psychiatrist to the
to the mafia
guy and i forgot the name of the movie
i'll analyze this
but that's it but he says to crystal doc
you're good you know you're very
well i i i definitely don't have a
medical license that i can assure you i
disbarred way back but no i it's really
is a high honor to talk to you and the
listener should know the book it's
called the centrist solution how we made
government work and can make it work
again i'm a believer joe lieberman i
want to see this happen and i would like
to get back to a world where compromise
is not a filthy word you know that's
that's the washington we're living in
now and it's my resolute hope that we
turn it around so you got to get out
there and sell some books man
thank you very much and and you're
you're really
making a difference by saying that to
your listeners so god bless you stay
well
you